this whole scene was filmed with a
practical creature really what
i've been watching since it came out
honestly
we lit this guy on fire more times than
any stunt performer had been lit on fire
in a single day wow
yeah
this might be one of the more graphic
versions of the shot no this is not it
was so much better than that
[Applause]
hey everyone welcome back to another
episode of visual effects today we've
got the legendary visual effects artist
behind jurassic park lord of the rings
babe 2 pig in the city seth rogen thank
you so much for joining us thanks for
having me not a lot of people know i do
all that stuff so it's nice to get
recognized finally for all that
i was 12 years old when i did jurassic
park
so yeah it's impressive so seth reached
out to us apparently he's a fan of the
show which is incredibly flattering and
i thought it'd be really fascinating to
talk to somebody who's been in the mix
of it as a director a producer an actor
and what their experience has been like
working with visual effects i know one
of the things we've talked about is the
challenge of trying to communicate ideas
to visual effects artists as a director
producer and work through that system
yeah there's been a lot of me being just
like it just doesn't look good and
this show has helped provide a
vocabulary that hopefully uh circumvents
that type of feedback
that's awesome well let's jump into some
clips we got some movies that seth has
worked on and been in and some classics
dude i've got some fun facts ready to
roll out i always
all right let's jump in
he did a movie called the interview
where
it's when one visual effects shot
becomes the most important shot in the
movie this conversation was ongoing
until the day the movie came out
basically which actually is a good
lesson because they're always like oh we
need the movie like
so much beforehand and we're always like
that's not true
you can change a shot 24 hours before
the movie is released and
it works and they make it happen they
get it out there
that looks great oh yeah it looks really
good
the shock wave and everything the the
way the metal deforms
yeah it's a really nice shot it was
really pretty
classic leaflets
getting lit on fire
this might be one of the more graphic
versions of the shot no this is not it
was so much better than that
why is there so much fire in front of
this head explosion that i'm sure looks
amazing but i can't see exactly so well
funny story
the largest act of corporate espionage
in history was perpetrated due to the
this film
that's right and
yeah north korea hacked into sony it
became it was an international news
story for weeks and obama
yeah remember there was a press
conference leading into the end of the
year and we were all watching it we're
like they won't talk about it they
talked about it for literally the entire
press conference
the studio was acting like he would be
on their side and he was not yes i think
they made a mistake we cannot have a
society in which some dictator someplace
can start imposing censorship here in
the united states he was essentially
like they should not have pulled it from
theaters they should not have listened
to north korea and their demands like
there's a terrible precedent to be
setting after obama gave that speech
they allowed theaters who wanted to show
it to show it and they sold it to google
uh play
to stream it this shot became the thing
that was like
unacceptable like of all the things in
the movie like if there was going to be
war with north korea based on something
in the movie it was going to be because
of this shot what the shot was is uh it
was like raiders of the lost ark we
built a
wax kim jong-un head
that had all the layers um and a skull
and brains and all this and there was it
had like an explosive charge like in the
middle yeah and i remember we like melt
we had like
these giant heat uh like lamps and
like that and we filmed it in really
high speed and like melted all the
layers and the ideas that would happen
in like a second
and then his head would pop
with the explosive charge um when he got
to the bottom
awesome it was very cool yeah and then
this became like the whole negotiation
was like how much of the head do you see
how much do you not see can we obscure
it with fire
literally the the studios have their own
visual effects uh people and they they
start changing the shot themselves doing
different versions of the shot showing
us versions of the shot um yeah it
literally becomes like a frame by frame
discussion
how many embers can hit his face how
long can it be on screen for like uh by
far the thing that i've had the most
discussion about in probably any one
single part of any movie i've ever had
anything to do with
tell your boss the green hornet sends
his regards hey mark
michelle gondry i love michelle gandry i
think his work is incredible he actually
came up uh if you ask him with the
bullet time thing before the matrix for
a smirnoff commercial that's right
that's right
was great and i learned a lot from him
and although that movie had like a
troubled path in some ways i still love
gondry and it was fun
some cool in it and we actually
i've been watching since it came out
honestly
see there's a classic audrey shot
we had a bunch of cars oh really oh yes
there was like a few cars that he
actually ran across that was one of
those things like you would like show up
on set and be like why is there four of
the same cars
all right
so this was actually really complicated
because the people are moving at
different frame rates you see the guys
falling yeah that's crazy that was
actually one of the things that gaundry
pitched when he first met on the movie
that cato hits a guy and before that guy
lands he's hit another guy it's done so
well it almost looks real it's a crazy
effect and all the bottle pieces are
slowly falling through the air too yeah
what's that rotoscoping nightmare i know
this is a tough scene
shooting two different speeds to beat in
the same shot is a really hard thing
because if the camera is moving
especially if the camera is moving yeah
the speed at which everything has to
like sync them off
yeah no it was really complicated it was
a lot of visual effects building little
bits of a jacket oh my god like that
that guy in front of him when he's going
in slow motion ko's going full speed
yeah exactly they have to rebuild cato
yep exactly
jesus
i have been there
popeye go forth
take these words and spread them
oh this sequence i remember this this
was cool and how he did this was really
interesting this is he's like sending uh
like people the word out to go kill the
green hornet and like it's like these
are like his thugs like spreading the
word and like
sending out that rv people yeah this is
cool
how does this keep
i'm curious
watching this it's cool
it's like in theory i totally see how
things are happening but like i'm
failing to see the actual like
method oh yeah it's really well done do
you guys know how he did it i don't it's
a lot more simple than you would think
every frame that splits they would
literally freeze continue the shot go
back to the freeze frame and start the
next shot oh wow so there they would
just freeze for one split second
continue following jamie harris and then
go back to that same frame and follow
these two women wow and then it would
just keep happening over and over and
over and over again basically and it's
like you can kind of hide the cut a
little bit by having that line come in
because it's drawing your eye away from
the fact that the scene is cutting yeah
i think literally it was gondry being
like freeze
it's like i'm realizing it actually does
require less coordination than i
initially anticipated like the film that
you've done that have bigger budgets
what's the biggest difference that
you've noticed
time and being able to physically build
your sets i would say um are the two
biggest things green horn is probably
like the biggest most expensive movie
i've worked on and you could just see
like we built
huge sets huge things we have huge set
pieces
physical giant things that that is just
expensive you know it's hard to do and
visual effects are something that like
are expensive well
that's like you could do a shot for ten
thousand dollars and you do shop for
eight thousand dollars and you do the
same shot right and and i think that's
what a lot of people don't realize it's
not even something i understood until
pretty recently is like we we really got
into the budgets of movies and we
remember we were looking at like the
budget of like blade runner 2049 in
their visual effects budget versus like
the point break remake and and i think
the same visual effects supervisor did
both those fins and you wanted oscar for
one and was probably like ragged on on
this show
and
and and he was the one who was like look
like this movie had like a hundred grand
per shot and this movie had like 10
grand per shot like which one do you
think think's gonna look better the one
where they're spending ten times more
per shot that one's gonna look better
and that's why visual effects
are scary for uh me and a lot of
filmmakers because you don't know
uh what you're gonna get necessarily and
it's something that you're kind of like
crossing your fingers sometimes just
hoping it's going to be good enough for
you and and you just like don't know you
know yeah exactly it's like the scope of
what you can actually get varies so much
and will scale to whatever that budget
is but unless you're a visual effects
artist
you don't really know inherently what
that's going to be no and then and it's
something that yeah you're kind of told
like it'll be good you'll be happy and
then like get it back and you're like i
don't think i'm happy and you're like
well that's it we're out of money they
won't do anything they're working on
something else now
[Laughter]
hey are you a big fan of lord of the
rings are you a bigger fan of the
extended editions of lord of the rings
well we're basically doing that with
these episode of visual effects artists
react we got extended cuts on the
website now if you want deeper stories
deeper in-depth knowledge basically
everything you love about the show but
just even more of it well that's exactly
what we have over on corridor
digital.com this episode in particular
is also going to be extended on the
website because you guys left comments
saying you wish the episodes were longer
and this is the end a giant monster gets
its penis sliced off by a laser from
heaven we can't do that on youtube but
we can do it on our website you can get
a free two-week trial or just start by
downloading the app from the app store
android and iphone and we got some crazy
shows on the way too oh yeah that's
right our show son of a dungeon our dnd
show is coming out in like a week or two
isn't it it's like almost done
but enough about that let's get back
into this episode
catch
get ready for a surprise
so what year did total recall come out
90. 90. summer of 1990 i think okay so
it's been a minute since i've actually
seen this movie it's a great movie it's
my mom's favorite movie okay
the thing i remember most from this
movie is just like his eyeballs bulging
out yeah but the mars atmosphere sucking
his eyes yeah i remember that just
terrifying me three-breasted woman
probably the thing i
[Laughter]
you remember now entering a safety zone
no unauthorized weapons allowed beyond
oh that's cool yeah hyper early for cg2
if you think about it wow that's all cg
right yeah wait 100 wow that looks good
it's the timing they got it
choreographed so perfectly so when
they're walking through this shot they
have the dog and they have the dog
skeleton yeah and the take that paul
liked the most the dog actually stops
and starts peeing oh that's on the other
side of the screen
so the animators had to go in and
animate the dog to look like the
skeleton is walking when behind this is
what it was actually
the person just drags it along
oh
yeah okay
it's a gun nobody's paying attention to
the x-rays
i love that was cool i love that so
inventive so are those 3d models of
skeletons
okay so those are actual renders yep all
right you guys want to hear some cool
facts yes
about these skeletons okay so they did a
motion capture with arnold
schwarzenegger where they put him in a
full suit and they put the white dots on
him and then none of it worked
just like most motion capture
so they're sitting there like what do we
do and thankfully for all these x-ray
scenes they actually had a camera on the
other side of the screen filming the
people walking by so they had reference
footage and they just straight up
rotoscope the animation on top of him it
looks good it looks really good and the
crazy thing is it's just people going in
and matching up those 3d models to his
motions frame by frame by frame to get
what looks like motion capture this
looks great yeah it's pretty incredible
[Music]
so let's take a look at another really
cool shot here so this is getting into
mars so good yeah it's like it's amazing
how far just simply good lighting goes
you know yeah just having that red light
stopping it at the right moment really
helps marry those two shots together i'm
pretty sure that's a miniature in the
background isn't it yep oh for sure this
whole thing is a miniature right i mean
i guess yeah it's like
that looks great
oh whoa whoa did you did you see that
what's that there was there was a merge
between two shots there were two
different models that were moving at
different seas right here oh yeah well
yeah like uh
it's funny kind of exactly i'm impressed
you caught that uh that split run so
this is all filmed in like a warehouse
so they built these giant miniatures so
they have that you know the big back
painting and they actually move it with
the camera so that it feels like it's
locked off wow that's cool because
things in the background don't move when
you move when they're miles and miles
away so that's the effect that they're
doing there to make it feel like all
those vistas and cliffs in the
background are actually a super far
distance away amazing that reminds me of
in lord of the rings they're forced
perspective shots with the moving camera
it's all about parallax i love
miniatures and i uh we're always pushing
to use them and they just don't let you
really yeah it's it's an argument i've
lost on many many many occasions is the
argument that like oh it's too expensive
yeah this is too hard it's too expensive
you need a whole unit to do it so you're
saying anytime you see like miniature
work in a movie that's because like the
director producer is just that powerful
well it's either like such a cheap movie
that there's no one gives a or
assassinating like yeah like i think
it's really amazing like what chris
nolan does with miniatures is really
amazing i think and it's a luxury and i
think like when you hear people be like
why don't you just do what crystal and
quentino do they don't let everyone do
that
they're convinced it looks like oh
the studios have this mentality that
like if it's old it just looks bad
that's kind of like in general what they
think and they don't like you to use
like what would be considered antiquated
technology to do things that are
supposed to look good they think their
fear is it'll look like kitschy or
something like that and then you're like
well chris nolan used it and they're
like yeah well he's fine
did you hear that
was this monster inspired by
ghostbusters well here's what's funny
this whole scene was filmed with a
practical creature really that was a
hundred percent replaced in post because
we just didn't like how it looked which
is funny because it goes against
everything i've just said
but yeah there was a guy
in a suit a demon suit and it looked
amazing and in real life it was
incredible it was scary it was gross and
then the guy in the suit whenever he
moved
it just was like not
what we wanted oh man i remember we this
poor guy like we had a long hallway in
the sound stage we were shooting in and
like me and evan must have made him run
down this hallway like a hundred times
as we filmed it and just like again more
animally again again again again our
visual effects supervisor uh paul linden
who's a great guy it was like i think i
can replace this thing with a big-ass
he was like honestly like i think you're
gonna want a big monster here like i
don't think you're gonna want like a
little human-sized guy in a suit and he
was right and then he replaced it with
this giant thing which was very much
inspired by the monster for the
ghostbusters to make a very long answer
the monster is actually like
surprisingly good like it does really
well i remember we were so skeptical of
me and evan i remember seeing like the
first version of it and being like oh my
god it's incredible like it's so much
better than i thought it was gonna be
yeah so did they have to remove the
other guy in the suit for those shots or
did you film those shots without the guy
in there i think we started very early
filming it without the guy i think we
took the guy out pretty fast
and i think to the guy we were like
don't worry it's great we have an idea
it's a it's more impressionist it's like
jaws the less you see the better it is
yeah it turned out really well it looks
really good like
this yeah like this shot was not at all
meant to be like that like the dude was
like cirque du soleil through the
background like sniffing around the
kitchen or some like that and like
all this was done in post there's
nothing blocking those lights in real
life it's incredible
yeah i remember seeing that shot and it
was just like what else could it do can
it yeah
like we just kept building more and more
and more and i remember like this house
we weren't happy with and we didn't
destroy it at all like we couldn't
damage it at all so all the damage
you're seeing in the house a hundred
percent of it is fake you know
it's like a nice house in new orleans
that we were like running around jay and
craig just being like it's over there
i didn't even think about that but
you're totally right it was like all
that was fake um and yeah they did a
nice job with it in the end
we burned this dude i think we burned
this guy i remember at the time the
stunt team telling us that we lit this
guy on fire more times than any stunt
performer had been lit on fire in a
single day wow
yeah that's great we've been on fire
like 18 times or something like that
this is largely practical that's crazy
which is insane fire's scary i have a
question about the fire so as jonah
hill's like running down the hallway
that actually does look like jonah's
face in that shot is that a digital
effect added after the fact is that
actually jonah on fire or is that the
prosthetic no it was face replacement we
have the guy run down on fire and we had
jonah doing a lot of the same action
just in camera we lined up the shot
jonah ran at the camera going
a few times and then we had the stunt
guy do the same thing and they use
visual effects to match it up and
probably rebuild some elements of his
face because i noticed in that shot
right there the very next shot it feels
like a problem yeah we probably just ran
out of money on that shot
pick and choose your battles what's
interesting though is jonah is never
wearing makeup in any sequence and the
real whole effect that done to him like
the kind of zombified uh like possessed
jonah is all cg wow that looks really
good yeah the whole thing was good i'm
not just saying that because you're on
the couch next no it really does look
good
honestly it was a good lesson because
like again it was one of those things we
didn't have a ton of money for
but yeah this dude was on fire on the
line
jumping down in front of us and that's
all the same shot
the fire behind us is fake i think yeah
something that i find interesting about
seeing this fire on camera and is part
of how i can tell the difference between
the practical fire and the added fire
later is how it's actually affecting the
optics of the lens and the sensor it's
flaring out in a really interesting way
and actually causing a bit of a color
shift yeah it has this like purple haze
to it most of the fire i'm seeing here
isn't actually generated by fire it's
filmed separately as an element and then
tracked into the shot fire is usually
pretty hard to composite and whoever did
this did a pretty good job at that they
did a good job and there was a lot of
real fire in the shot to compare it to
which sure made it easier
it was mayhem like uh everyone was like
there is way too much fire
i heard this story about channing tatum
yes in this
channel introduce yourself
hey what's up guys y'all cool
it's channing tatum um how much time was
there between when you sent him an email
asking him to be in the movie and when
you actually shot with him
maybe a few weeks
or something like that and i remember
telling him like
you're guys wearing a mask for a lot of
it like you don't have to do this is
this him for the whole season
there is never a stunt performer
it is him for two nights like
we were very specific like we see your
face once for one second he's like i
want to do all of it
[Laughter]
you got to be chatting to do that oh my
gosh
visual effects are something that like
it's a hard thing to navigate at times
and again watching this show is has made
me think of it differently i think
because you don't often see the movie
through the perspective of the of the
visual effects people and it's helpful
so you think other directors should
watch the show i think they should yeah
if they work with visual effects
definitely yeah
quentin tarantino uh yeah you know chris
nolan
this has been an utter treat this has
been one of the most fun episodes if not
the most fun episode we've ever done and
i cannot thank you enough for being here
seth seriously thanks for having me i
mean is there anything you want us to
like kind of like push the audience to
like um watch the films of paul
verhoeven
i recommend that watch total recall if
you haven't seen it the robocop it's
probably on netflix yeah great it's
great yeah come check out total recall